nice a rich et économiste essayiste
auteur de l'ouvragé algérie histoire
secrète d'un naufrage annoncé aux
éditions l'harmattan
bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté à
notre invitation sur arte france alors
comment vous interprétez vous les
déclarations d' emmanuel macron tout
d'abord dans les colonnes de jeune
afrique
oui bonjour en fait c'est vraiment de
l'improvisation est ce que monsieur
macro est mal conseillé à deux et puis
lui même il n'a pas une pratique des
relations internationales anciennes et
aux voies que il a glissé sur un terrain
qui est vraiment mines et celui des
relations sensible entre l'algérie et la
france
moi même j'ai conduit plusieurs
délégations d'hommes d'affaires de
femmes d'affaires en algérie depuis 86
et en sang à chaque fois même si un
député de l'opposition
n'importe quel responsable politique
français dès qu'il parle de l'algérie
les mots sont décortiqués sont analysés
et il y a une sensibilité de d algérie
avisé de la france en tant que puissance
coloniale avec tout le passé qu'on
connaît le traumatisme causé par cette
collision colonisation donc il fallait
plus dans mes dires sur la bouche du
président de la république qu'il va
aider monsieur tebboune donc ça veut
dire qu'il va s'agir et dans les
relations internes à l'algérie ça veut
dire qu'il va s'impliquer mais comment
et en plus il y a une situation que tout
le monde connaît que j'ai vous avez eu
l'amabilité de citer cet ouvrage ou
jeudi la lutte depuis l'indépendance au
sein de l'algérie c'est entre la
présidence de la république et l'armée
et on va pas qu'est ce qu'ils sur quoi
ils s'appuient pour soutenir le
président on ne sait pas actuellement
pourquoi
monsieur tebboune il est en allemagne
depuis un certain temps qu'est ce qui se
trame
le régime algérien c'est l'un des plus
secrets le plus opaque et j'ai eu le cet
honneur d'avoir vous faire beaucoup de
recoupements pour décortiquer depuis
l'indépendance ses relations complexes
entre la président de la république et
l'armée donc et en plus là il ya quand
même le peuple algérien c'est pas rien
c'est il ya un mouvement un mouvement il
faut pas prendre acte de ce mouvement
qui qu'ils aient cessé de manifester
mais à cause du coc vide 82 2019
mais pour le moment nous ne savons pas
grand chose de ce qui se trame au sommet
de l'état entre monsieur tebboune et
l'appareil militaire parce que est ce
que cette maladie et les réelles pas
réel
on n'en sait rien et donc je pense que
viser de l'algérie il faut rester dans
un dans un discours qui est très
diplomatique pour un chef d'état
est-ce que vous pensez que ces
déclarations des macros on sait que cet
entretien accordé à jeune afrique
on a bien senti que le président
français était dans dans une stratégie
de reconquête un peu du continent
africain
de défense aussi du de ce qu'on appelle
le pré carré français coupant ce que
c'est dans cette optique là justement
qu'il a fait cette déclaration au risque
comme on le disait de provoquer l'ire de
l'opposition algérienne
je pense qu'il n'a pas mesuré vu qu'il
manque d'expérience en relations
internationales
c'est un drame en france que le fait que
c'est les relations internationales
ils sont devenues marginales du point de
vue de la connaissance l'interprétation
mais aussi du conte série les erreurs
monumentales on voit sur plusieurs
dossiers qui s'accumulent et compris les
conseillers comment il
ils agissent il faut avoir en mémoire
toute l'histoire toutes toutes les
complexités et là c'est raté
je dis bien c'est raté parce que il
s'agit pas là l'eau tollé général
soulevé dans la presse algérienne ch et
toute l'opposition qui est très sensible
à juste titre de toute déclaration des
chefs d'état français et il accuse
d'ingérence de vouloir s'immiscer dans
des relations intérieures et en plus il
y à ce mouvement qui ce qui est toujours
là rappelons aussi que le vote le
référendum pour la constitution
algérienne par rocchi plus réellement
plus de 3 4%
on a vu des véhicules de l'armée en
civil se promener pour vanter enfin on
connaît très bien la situation
algérienne et il est aussi dommage que
que le ministère de le credo c'est ne
soit pas à l'écouté du terrain il ils
sont coupés de la réalité algérienne
pour faire remonter le chef de l'état ce
qui se passe le ressenti d algérie à
l'euro sont idéales gien et puis un
sentiment aussi qui se développe qui
aussi suite au aux caricatures de
du prophète mahomet et cetera les
déclarations macro là-dessus et c'est
tout ça ça crée un climat un climat qui
vraiment pas pas propice à un discours
positif en plus il dit un commissariat
l'algérie ne respectent pas les
standards mais les standards il ya pas
que les cependant on voit bien ce qui se
passe aux etats unis la démocratie
étasunienne et la démocratie française
ne sont pas le modèle pour tous les pays
rivoire mairie - merci avoue camille
sari sera pas que vous êtes économiste
essayer son auteur de l'ouvragé ray
histoire secrète d'un naufrage annoncé
aux éditions l'harmattan